do white lives matter White lives uh
it's a bit of a tricky question
um no imagine that it's a bit of a
tricky question I'm so afraid to say
that they matter not in the slightest
yes they tried to censor the truth no
why not black lives matter I really
don't give a [ __ ] about white lives
we're gonna get really political I don't
want to go there all lives matter it
shows
all lives matter I'm glad that brother
put that out there because he started a
whole bunch of concert conversation man
you're hard to talk to really why
because you're making me think that all
my answers are wrong there's no right or
wrong answer it's just your opinion
a minute almost up did you go oh my God
when he said all lives matter because
like before you explained it it was like
it was like looking isn't it crazy that
that's a political statement I mean I
guess it's like if I say
[Music]
hey
then I don't know I don't want to talk
about it I don't like white people
why not I just don't
for no reason yeah for no reason a bit
of a tricky question like do I even need
to like say the hypocrisy like that's to
the point where we're just like what you
just just move on you know what I mean
like that's just so stupid I don't have
anything to say to that schmuck to be
honest because I saw the uh fuss around
Kanye West's White lives matter and I
absolutely didn't agree with the way it
was provoking so I would say black lives
matter White lives matter no black lives
matter it's like why
listen to yourself it makes me really
sad that people are this stupid it's sad
that you can say that and how you can
look back at the whole movement and what
they did with coven and BLM and not
realize that you were fooled even all
the black people that I talk to nowadays
realize they're like yeah that was a
scam I knew what while it was happening
that it was a scam I was watching I was
reading their the black lives matter.org
website reading through their mission
statement reading through all the work
they were doing and it was all horseshit
they rug pulled all of it they rug
pulled we all know that they haven't
actually given any money to anybody or
made anybody's live lives any better for
her to sit here and not understand that
all of it is racist that anti-racism is
racist because again anti-racism part of
that is you understanding how horrible
your whiteness is it's not racist enough
enough because as a black man
it was a bit odd it was weird to to do
that why is it odd because it was not
what you would
expect it was not really political
correct like what Kanye West dad said he
said anything it was really funny
because it was a black man stating the
obvious why lives matter there's no
reason to get upset about it it's funny
that it's Politically Incorrect to say
that your life matters yeah
do you think he's crazy
I think it's quite crazy is yay crazy
Kanye I love Kanye
he sold a shirt that said White lives
matter
oh [ __ ] Kanye is he crazy
he's crazy crazy
why you say that
he's crazy
what has he done that made makes you
think that he's crazy this girl has like
a half a brain can we do we really even
need to watch her I'm getting Dumber by
the second he's just crazy
for no reason yeah for no reason
and bring Ox Offspring can you define
what crazy is
Kanye
he's the definition of crazy you think
that Kanye West is crazy stupid you know
this is like the worst combination of
things smug and stupid is by far the
worst oh God when they think they know
everything and they're saying about [ __ ]
[ __ ] idiots I think
[Music]
yeah this
is what happened with Tate we've talked
about this work they did it with Kanye
and I recently learned that Kanye is
brilliant I don't agree with everything
he says so calm down I'm I'm not an
anti-semite actually I will stand I
stand up for Israel and the Jews all day
long in case anybody is gonna accuse me
of that because I don't want to hang
Kanye watching his interview with Tucker
Carlson I really realized how
intelligent he was and how how deep it
goes and all I've ever seen are clips
and out of context videos and
information I've told you this for years
you always every time I mention Kanye
you you would say he's crazy and you
didn't like the way they the way he was
or whatever I don't really remember
talking about Kanye for years that not
for you like you know what I mean like
every time I mention him you're like oh
that guy's an [ __ ] I I never said he
was an [ __ ] I don't ever remember
thinking he was an [ __ ] I remember
thinking um it looks like he's bipolar
or [ __ ] crazy and I know now that
that's what the media portrayed him as
he's not and so I'm watching these girls
and I can't even you know it's
unfortunate because these girls just
have bought the Kool-Aid or excuse me
bought the narrative they really they
haven't watched any I guarantee they
haven't watched a full hour-long
interview with him where they get to
understand his mind at least a little
bit better Pierce I make more money than
you so you should listen to me why would
I listen to you exactly so take my
advice maybe you'll get richer I would
love to take your businesses why would I
listen to you that Kanye West is crazy
absolutely why
have you seen the news recently yeah why
is she just absolutely crazy no one
should be saying from last night like is
this the morning and that's just she's
Walker shaming home she's a pretty girl
though
yeah you would say to yay if he was
watching this
I'm [ __ ] up all your best deals calm
down like drink some tea and get back on
your [ __ ] medication arcade meditate
I love you can you explain to me because
I read his anti-semitic tweets and I
read it again and it was it if you just
took that and that was your whole
impression of Kanye it did sound crazy I
didn't even fully understand what he was
talking about I think it had something
to do with the fact that there were you
know a lot of very powerful Jewish
people in Hollywood and the music
industry who he felt have betrayed him
which we know there are I mean the Jews
have had their asses kicked for
thousands of years and they're running
[ __ ] you know they always just get up
they don't complain you don't hear them
complaining about what happened two
thousand fifteen hundred a thousand
three hundred even less than 100 years
ago they don't complain they just get up
and they're like I'm gonna take [ __ ]
over watch this I love them I admire
them his tweets did you understand them
I think it was just to get a reaction
out of people to be quite honest it's a
shitty way to get a reaction
because I understand what he's saying
and when you talk like I actually listen
to his whole interviews and stuff it
makes sense he's like yeah like the
Jewish people in the media they're on
the banks like yes everyone we know this
stuff and he's like yes they they've
been using people and taking advantage
of them specifically the black community
and the music industry stuff like this
but just like okay you obviously know
stuff that we don't know 100 I'm not
saying you're right or wrong there I'm
saying you would know more than me but I
I just I thought the Tweet was it's just
a weird way to go about it that he's
crazy
thing comes to the news and I saw it and
it's a little bit crazy yeah if you're
not that familiar why do you think he's
crazy
um because sometimes I will look it at
the news and just to get information
from the news should we believe
everything we see in the news
um yeah I think the only thing I can do
is trust news because I have no other
information comes from other
anywhere else
I'm sorry that's it stop no because this
see you go bot and I go this is part of
her learning curve in life she just
hasn't gotten there yet where she wakes
up and says this is horseshit she needs
something here's what needs to happen
something needs to happen in her life
that she saw firsthand and then she
could go read it in the news and go what
the what that's unfortunately what needs
to happen uh to everybody the second he
asked he asked that question I knew they
were going to say yes yes I do but she
says I have no other source of
information but like truly where what
other source is there besides knocking
on Kanye's door and being like hey dude
can we have a cup of coffee together so
I can get to know who you are well not
reading well specifically to this
situation not just reading the headlines
actually like listening to long-form
content of him talking
I honestly didn't support black lives
matter because the money put into that
program was usurped and put into other
people's pockets isn't it crazy that as
a black man he's like I don't know if I
should say I don't support black lives
matter that's wild and he has a super
logical reason for it the money came in
the money went we don't know it didn't
help anybody didn't help a single black
Life One refund yeah they should all go
to [ __ ] jail because if anybody else
collected money for in a non-profit and
did not do with with that money what
they what did they say their mission
statement said if you open a non-profit
you have to fill out all this paperwork
and have these very this very specific
Mission and you're only allowed to use
the money that you collect for that
mission and in certain ways there are a
tremendous amount of books and books of
laws on how to how you can collect and
spend money yeah and the fact that they
didn't do any of what they said they
were going to do and they did no good
like [ __ ] need to be behind
bars yeah it's crazy and they are being
investigated didn't I can't wait and if
they do go behind bars I can't guarantee
you that the liberal media will not
cover one second of it not one if
anything accomplished for black lives
matter hell no
just more separation divine
you think it was one big scam yes
the truth
you think Kanye West is crazy is yay
crazy hell no I support you I love Kanye
West yo Kanye West I love you I love
Kanye West I support Kanye West I always
have all my life
why do you think people are calling them
crazy I think people say he's crazy
because they don't want them to hear
what he's really saying which might be
influential you're going to set a crazy
ass goal getting Conway on our podcast
Conway did I say Conway yeah yeah we can
we'll get him on the Pod come right like
he's some white guy who went to Milton
Academy Conway you have lacrosse
practice tonight Conway oh you're gonna
be at the polo match this weekend no I
do but seriously like I want to get
Kanye on a podcast I want to talk to
that mess that would be sick can you do
that I'll work on it I think that Trump
deserves to be banned off of social
media I think Trump deserves a life in
prison for treason or worse
he doesn't deserve anything
no no rights at all Trump doesn't
deserve any rights at all no more than
that I think he's I think he should be a
convicted felon and have those uh you
know everything else stripped of him you
don't see convicted felons sitting in
giving you an interview Kanye it's sad
that someone can be that brainwashed and
want that much horrible stuff to happen
to a human that's like almost that's
just like pure evil it's religious
especially without reason because you
know sneako is going to ask him I've
been watching this whole video but you
know sneaker's gonna ask him why do you
hate Trump what did he do and he's gonna
say
he called he called Mexicans rapist or
some some [ __ ] excited and
Insurrection and yeah a bunch of other
lies that he heard on CNN let's go I
think that Kanye West should be
embarrassed for himself uh his
anti-Semitism is disgusting and uh and
he's a disgusting individual should he
be banned from social media if I ran the
social media company he would be banned
what's one thing you would say to yay if
he was watching this two thumbs down I
wouldn't talk to the man
he's he's disgusting human being there
was a an incident in Los Angeles today
attributed to him where people were
showing banners over the free one of the
things that the Tates taught snico was
how if you have 10 000 people watching
you there's gonna be 300 absolute nut
jobs that watch your stuff yeah and so
even though whatever you're talking
about red pill stuff talking about women
those people are genuinely crazy so they
might go they might go and shoot up a
school or some horrible [ __ ] and they're
going to do it in the name of whatever
you said is that really your fault or
are they just not jobs Kanye is right
the Jews need to die is that really his
fault absolutely it's his fault he's
take responsibility for other people
misinterpreting his message not not
misinterpreting
they're repeating his message very
different than misinterpreting
misinterpretations can be corrected
but repeating his message is very clear
the message he said that he was going to
go death quote Defcon 3 on Jews and uh
and as a matter of fact his followers
are
you know making anti-semitic statements
and the Jews should die kind of
statement
what followers who I I just said I like
Kanye and I love the Jews and I think
that they're better than pretty much all
of us who was it I'm not going to say
which one but one of the base grandmas
in a conversation off camera said that
she thinks the Jews are the superior
race
what we need to do is start to think
about Humanity as a whole about whether
or not we all matter because the way
things are going right now
it seems like nobody's life matters man
look at home the homeless population
look at the jail population
mental health we have a mental health
crisis food crisis
nobody's life matters that really does
feel like how we're living I can
guarantee that it feels like there's an
attack on white people and white
people's lives don't matter because you
can't even say White lives matter
anymore it's it's like can you say could
you say Hispanic lives matter could you
say Asian lives matter yeah that's all
okay but if you say White lives matter
that's a problem and then as a white
person you can't even say your real
thoughts or else you're racist I I don't
know I feel like I'm constantly being
attacked for being white that's just the
way I personally feel you are because if
you think if now you're watching this
and then you're like how could you say
that because you're white you're proving
my point I think I was aware of the
whole you know white people bad thing
before you were and I'm also I have the
benefit of age on you where I'm past it
I'm over it when someone tells me that
I'm bad because I'm white or I have this
or I'm not I'm just literally rolling my
eyes and think
dummy like it just it sounds so stupid
to me now I can't be offended by it it's
like being offended by a little kid if a
three-year-old looks at you and says
you're fat you know you can cry yourself
to sleep if you're a [ __ ] emotional
idiot or you know I have no emotional
intelligence so you can be like oh my
God little kids are funny oh you silly
goose and you keep going that's how I
look at people that say that's me I look
at them like they're a toddler having a
tantrum or a dog barking I can't get
offended by a dog barking do you
understand what I'm saying and that's
how I look at it and you you'll get
there but I understand why you're still
pissed because you're just a young man
and I couldn't just acknowledge that
it's happening but I don't get pissed
about it you seem a little pissed it's
okay oh maybe I am it's okay to be a
little pissed there is yeah you can have
emotional intelligence and still get a
little pissed because shit's wrong it's
wrong and we should be angry about it we
should let our anger run our [ __ ]
lives but we should be angry about it
race this is racism you're bad because
you're white that's racism why is why do
we have to keep saying this how many
people still are out there that need to
hear this that's crazy let's go get them
sit them in the [ __ ] tie into the
[ __ ] seat until they understand you
think Kanye West is crazy
I think the brother as a clinical social
worker the brother needs to definitely
be on medication I think he definitely
is exhibiting symptoms of bipolar
disorder and he needs to be on
medication what's one thing you could
tell yay right now if he was watching
this
brother man
get your mental health in order and then
come back and say all the stuff you've
been saying as a clinical psychologist
she thinks that Kanye is bipolar and
needs help and needs medication you know
I'd be curious to see how he came to
that conclusion was it because of the
short form content or was it because he
saw long form content and he has a
really intelligent explanation for that
yep that's a good point who knows I mean
I don't know what he was it sounds
pretty intelligent it raised the
question you'd like to think that he'd
walk he's he saw the long-form contest I
like this guy though and he's saying
because like like tweeting that like his
tweet was a little crazy like that's
that's a wild ass thing to tweet
honestly you know what I would say like
if he was a woman I'd be like maybe she
just had PMS because like get you know
not all not all women some women skate
through it like it's nothing but for the
men out there listening you got to know
what kind of girl you got you got to
know if you got a girl there's a few bad
days a month just stay the [ __ ] out of
the way that's my advice I think you're
you're so simple trying to trying to say
this is censorship but I don't I don't
believe that censorship is punishment I
see it as punishment I'd like it to be
punishment punish you I think when it's
the ex-president that's a level of
censorship because that's an influence
you're thinking about him as a man
Donald Trump as a person but this is
somebody who was the leader of the Free
World
well I don't believe he was the leader
of the Free World
the title but you understand what I'm
saying up to put in the way that he did
in hell in uh Helsinki cozying up to Kim
Jong-un ill that he did in South Korea
and that makes him by association my
point is that singling out and like
trying to point it at his ego and saying
that he's addicted to Twitter is
minimizing the fact that you're seeing a
Justice punishment when a lot of people
probably should hear what the
ex-president of the United States has to
say that's what I think
okay you're welcome to your opinion oh
it says that now now you're welcome Oh
no you're welcome to your opinion but
all sense of your ass if you say
anything else I disagree with punishment
not censorship opinion is is you know
put them on an ice flow and set them out
in the sea and let them melt let the
whales eat them up I mean and I know
that he's being he's joking there and
some should be sensed to death
treason is punishable by death
no no I don't think he's evil I
guarantee you that guy does some good
things in his community he's he's
clearly he looks like an educated
successful man probably has good
relationships he probably does things in
his community he's just so misguided by
his Echo chamber he's he refuses to get
out of the echo chamber where they're
all just saying oh he's bad yes he's bad
let me tell you something else he did
today oh he's bad let me tell you
something else he did today and that's
what's sad is that we have some people
are just dumb asses this isn't educated
clearly looks like a successful man and
he buys it because he doesn't understand
that he needs to see the whole picture
not just the talking head on the news
who isn't giving you facts they're
giving out opinions these days how could
a man not educated not see that is
[ __ ] too much too much for my brain
makes me very upset that was a great
video sneaker made I'm glad he's still
making videos even though he's banned I
love sneak out okay he's my fave of all
the ones we've reacted to since it was
my faith thank you guys so much for
watching make sure to join the Discord
of my bio you can drop stuff for us to
react to there and I just launched my
full Academy where you can learn to make
money online and use social media to
your advantage that's what I've been
doing for the last two years so it's
pretty cool stuff there there's actually
a lot of extra cool stuff in that
Academy too
[Music]
[Music]